southern nevada bracing for the extreme
heat ted's been talking about with
temperatures climbing to 115 degrees
this week
that heat easily can cause air
conditioning units to just shut down
kate houston went out on a service call
with yes air conditioning to break down
common problems
and some signs to watch out for keeping
your ac running will be important for
both comfort
and safety yes air conditioning says a
little maintenance will go a long way
starting to be a pretty busy week crews
with yes air conditioning are already
swamped
with calls beginning morning to middle
of the night
peter almanza says many emergencies are
due to a lack of maintenance during
spring
changing filters regularly helps with
the temperature in the house
if you do not change that will not
remove the proper air from the house and
your system will actually run more
and work harder a few warning signs that
your ac may give out soon
consistently high power bills and the
system taking too long to reach a
slightly lower
temperature almanza says it's important
to know the signs
but don't try to troubleshoot it
yourself they do have more
wires more controls more electricity
that and handling the refrigerant does
take
good care having the hoses and the
proper tools to take care of the unit is
probably the most important thing
if you're out of the house this time of
year almanza says the ac
still needs to stay on just at a higher
temperature
otherwise it can do more damage your
unit will actually work harder
it will run longer your house will heat
up higher
to a higher temperature indoor and you
will have to
use quite a bit of energy to cool that
house down
kate houston 8 news now kate thanks if
you have two ac units in your home and
only one shuts down yes air conditioning
says that will need to be quickly
fixed if left to one unit it will cost
too much energy and cause more damage
leading to more costly repairs from
personal experience i can say that's
true
yeah for sure brian as the heat